There are many more
advanced learning algorithms, then
the regression based approaches and
they generally attempt to direct the
optimizer retrieval measure.
like MAP or nDCG.
Note that
the optimization objective function
that we have seen on the previous slide
is not directly related to retrieval
measure
By maximizing the prediction of one
or zero, we don't necessarily
optimize the ranking of those
documents.
One can imagine that why our
prediction may not be too bad.
Let's say both are around .5, so
it's kinda of in the middle of zero and
one for the two documents.
But the ranking can be wrong, so we
might have got a larger value for
D2 and than D1.
So that won't be good from retrieval
perspective, even though by likelihood
function is not bad.
In contrast, we might have another case
where we predicted values all around
.9, let's say
and by the objective functioning
the error will be larger, but if we can
get the order of the two documents
correct, that's actually a better
result.
So these new, more advanced approaches
will try to correct that problem.
Of course, then the challenge is that the
optimization problem would be harder to
solve and then researchers have
proposed many solutions to the problem
and you can read more
reference at the end to know more about
the these approaches.
Now these learning to rank approaches
are actually general, so they can also be
applied to many other ranking problems,
not just the retrieval problem.
So here I list some, for example
recommender systems, computational
advertising or summarization and
there are many others that you can
probably encounter in your
applications.
To summarize this lecture we have
talked about the using machine learning
to combine multiple features to improve
ranking results.
Actually the use of machine learning in information
retrieval has started since many
decades ago.
So, for example, the Rocchio feedback
approaches that we talked about earlier
was machine learning approach applied
to relevance feedback
But the most recent use of machine
learning has been driven by some
changes in the environment of
applications of retrieval systems, and
first,
it's mostly driven by the availability
of a lot of training data in the form
of click throughs.
Such data won't available before, so
the data can provide a lot of
useful knowledge about the relevance
and machine learning methods can be
applied to leverage this.
Secondly, it's also driven by the need
for combining many features and this is
not only just because there are more
features available on the web that can
be naturally used to improve scoring,
it's also because by combining them
we can improve the robustness of
ranking, so this is desired for
combating spams.
Modern search engines are all used,
some kind of machine learning
techniques combined with many
features to optimize ranking and this
is a major feature of these commercial
engines such as Google or Bing.
The topic of learning to rank is still
active research topic in the community
and so you can expect to see new
results being developed
in the next few years, perhaps.
Here are some additional readings that
can give you more information about how
learning to rank works and also some
advanced methods.